So my name is Wale.
I'm the technical lead for
the Android Window Manager
and Activity Manager.
Today I'm going to be
presenting what we're doing
to support multi-window mode.
It's going to be a relatively
short presentation, mainly
because I want to give you
all a chance, at the end,
to ask any questions
you may have
relating to your specific
use in multi-window mode.
OK, so multi-window
allows multiple activities
to be visible on screen
at the same time.
The activities are resizeable
from the full screen area
down to a minimum
size, as allowed
by the system or activity.
In the end, we're going
to be supporting three
forms of multi-window mode.
Split-screen multi-window
mode, with two activities,
obviously, side-by-side.
And a divider in
the middle can be
used to give more
or less screen space
to one activity or the other.
Picture-in-picture
multi-window mode,
where an activity
is z-ordered always
on top of all of the
activities on screen.
And freeform
multi-window mode, where
multiple activities are visible
on screen at the same time.
They can be moved around
freely and also resized
to any average area dimension.
So some important things, in
the end, to keep in mind--
the Android activity
lifecycle model
is not going to be changing
in multi-window mode.
We're still only going to
have one resumed activity
in the system at a time.
And all other visible
activities are
going to be in the
paused visible state.
There are several reasons we are
keeping this model on Android.
And one of the main reasons
is, being in the resume state
is an important
indicator to the system
on what kind of resources
an activity can acquire,
because it, kind of, has
highest important score.
For example, the camera service
discovers singleton resource.
And the resumed
activity is always
going to get that
resource compared
to all other activities that
are in the paused state.
Another important
thing to note is
that we are now also factoring
in the low memory score
adjustment of visible
activities in the paused state
using a z-order.
For those of you
that don't know,
the low memory score
just got on Android.
It's basically an
important score given
to all processes in the system.
The higher your score,
the more important
you are to the system.
And the more the system
will try to keep you alive.
And when the system is
running low on resources,
it kills things that are of
lower importance score first.
Right, so for example, you
can have a service showing
in your background, and you
cannot be resumed activity.
And the system-- when it's
running low on resources--
would kill these services
running in the background
first before the resumed
activity that the user might
be interacting with.
So similar for
visible activities
that are in the
paused state-- we,
kind of, rank them in
order of their z-order
and give them an appropriate
low memory score adjustment.
So if the system is really,
really, running low on memory
and it needs to kill
visible activities,
it's going to start from the one
with the lower z-order first.
However, when the
system does that,
we do preserve the
current window on screen
so it's still
visible to the user.
And we apply it
dimly on top of it.
Once the user interacts
with the app again,
we then bring it back to life.
Something else that
is important to note
is that, as of N, since it
isn't desirable for video apps
to stop video playback when
they are in the paused state,
the new recommendation,
as of N, is for video apps
to handle play/pause actions
in-- on start on stop
versus on resume on pause.
While it has always
been the case in Android
that a paused activity
can still be visible,
it has not been as
visible to the user
as it will be with multi-window.
So it's a message right
now pushing for it
a little bit stronger now that--
on what the various lifecycle
stages represent.
When you're on start,
it means you're
going to be visible soon.
On resume means you are
visible both and focused
On pause, means you are still
visible but not focused.
And on stop, means you
are no longer visible.
So another thing to note is
that as the user resizes you up
in multi-window mode, we do
issue configuration changes.
However, we only limit
these configuration changes
to the configurations that
would cause new resources
to be loading you up.
So, for example, if you
are past two buckets
where it has a layout
representation for portrait
and one for landscape-- and
as the user resizes you up
in portrait mode, if they are
not crossing a threshold that
will cause it to
switch orientation,
we do not issue new
configuration changes
or cause the app to relaunch.
However, once they cross
that configuration threshold
and new resources
need to be loaded,
we do reissue the configuration
change for landscape mode.
It's also important to
note that the configuration
change that I'm
referring to here
only applies to the
activity on screen
and not the overall
device configuration.
So the device can
be in landscape mode
while your activity
in multi-window mode
can be in portrait mode.
Also, as you do today,
you can continue
to undo configuration
changes to avoid relaunches.
In order to avoid relaunches
in multi-window mode,
you need to undo all
the configurations
you have on screen.
Screen size, smaller
screen size, screen layout,
and orientation.
If you choose not to undo
the configuration changes,
you will be relaunching
and resizing.
However, we do preserve your
current window on screen
until you render your
content into a new window.
And we'll replace
it seamlessly, so
that the experience to the
user is not jarring and appears
as smooth as possible.
So there are several
new APIs we're
going to being introducing
in order to better support
multi-window mode.
I'm going to be going
over a few of these APIs.
So the big one is the resizeable
activity manifest attribute.
This is an attribute that you
set to indicate to the system
that your activity supports
multi-window and can be resized
to any operator dimension.
It's important to note that
we enabled this activity,
by default, for all apps,
including the ones not
targeting N. And you need
to explicitly tag it N
and set it to false in order to
disable-- not that we recommend
that, though, for all apps.
Another important
thing to note is
that the root activity
of a task determines
the resizeability of that task.
You can think of a task
as every single card entry
you see in the recent activity
or [INAUDIBLE] activity.
So if the root activity
is marked as resizeable,
any additional activity
that goes into that task
is also resizeable.
However, if the root activity
isn't resizeable, then
no other activity in that task--
the task will not be resized.
So no other activity in that
task will be resized, as well.
Another cool new
API we are adding
is the launch adjacent API.
With the launch
adjacent flag, you
can launch an activity
adjacent to yourself
while in split-screen
multi-window mode.
For example, I have on screen
the Chrome activity on one side
with an address link.
An implementation
could be done where,
once you click on
that address link,
the map activity is
launched adjacent
to the Chrome activity.
So an activity can also
use the layout styleable,
mostly in freeform
multi-window mode,
to set its initial
or default launching
position on size on screen.
You can set things like
your default height, weight,
gravity-- whether you want to
be on top, center, bottom--
what the minimum dimensions
you allow the user to resize
your application to.
So in multi-window mode, as
the user resizes your activity,
the layout of your app
can be slow depending
on your implementation, right?
So what a user would
notice is, kind of,
an effect where they perform
an action in the old way
here, right, and the
app is still, kind of,
taking time to re-layout to
catch up to the user action.
That experience is
not too desirable.
So what we're
actually doing in N,
is we introduce a second UI
thread in the application
process to draw a
background color that
keeps in line with
the user action
as the main app's
UI thread takes time
to render content to catch
up to the user action.
You can use the window
background styleable
to customize what this color is.
So picture-in-picture
mode, while it's
desirable for most
apps to support
picture-in-picture-- to
support multi-window mode--
it doesn't make
sense for all apps
to support picture-in-picture
mode multi-window.
For example, you would expect
an app like Netflix or YouTube
to support
picture-in-picture mode.
But you didn't expect
an app like Google Docs
to support
picture-in-picture mode.
So to differentiate this
form of multi-window mode,
we have the supports
picture-in-picture mode
manifest attribute for
the app to indicate
that it can go into this mode.
With apps that have this
flag set, on devices
that support
picture-in-picture mode,
they can call the enter
picture-in-picture mode API
to put themselves into
picture-in-picture mode.
A few things to keep in mind
with picture-in-picture mode
is even though the
activity is z-ordered
on top of all other
activities in the system,
it is actually in the
paused visible state.
And the activity
that is full screen
below the
picture-in-picture activity
is, actually, in
the resume state.
And the main reason
for doing this
is, once the user
puts your activity
into picture-in-picture
mode, they really
want to watch your
activity to the side
while interacting with
the full screen activity.
So it makes sense
for the activity
to be focused and resumed
while your activity is
in the visible paused state.
It's also important to keep
in mind that you can continue
to use the media session APIs
we have today while you're
in picture-in-picture mode to
keep track of media buttons,
like play/pause
actions and whatnot.
We also have APIs that
allow you to get notified
whenever the system
or the user puts you
into multi-window
mode, or whenever
you exit multi-window motor
and picture-in-picture mode.
And you can also
query the system
on your client's window mode.
In freeform mode, activity
is allowed to display content
next to the caption/title area
using the overlay with the call
caption API.
You can kind of think
about the Chrome tabs
you have on your
computer where the Chrome
tabs are next to the
window control buttons.
With this API, you can, kind
of, do something similar.
Also in freeform
mode, an activity
can launch another activity at
a specific location and size
on the screen using the activity
option set launch bounds API.
So currently on
Android we support
several APIs that affect the
entire screen configuration.
You can think of the nav bar,
status bar customization,
for example.
And this customization
for the entire screen
would have conflict
in multi-window mode,
especially when apps require
conflicting configuration.
So through that
effect, we have most
of this configuration as
disabled when the apps are
in multi-window mode.
I have some of the
examples listed on screen,
like the system UI
customization for status bar,
nav bar-- show wallpaper
behind-- immersive mode,
and setting orientation.
Something important to note
with setting orientation--
once you say your app is
compatible with multi-window
mode, having a fixed
orientation doesn't really
make sense in that
world anymore,
since the user can,
kind of, resize
your app to any dimension,
and it can change orientation
while changing that dimension.
So it kind of makes sense
for that to be disabled,
regardless of the
conflict you might have.
So some UX best
practices and guidelines
for multi-window
mode include, you
will provide a single responsive
UI for your application
so that the user has a
consistent experience
while using your application
on the same device
at different sizes.
You'll start by designing your
app for the most challenging
use case so you can uncover
architectural problems early
in the design process.
And you'll follow the
material design patterns
so that your app has
a consistent look
and feel with other apps
running on the system.
And we-- you want to only
disable multi-window mode
when justified.
It's-- it would be odd if most
apps on the user device go
into multi-window mode.
And your app is the odd one out.
And the user launches it, and it
launches into full screen mode.
And look for various places to
take advantage of all the APIs
we're exposing for multi-window
mode, like the launch
adjacent for
appropriate use cases.
So some more guidelines
and best practices--
we recommend that apps with
similar layout for phones
and tablets may use the
phone tablets on-- I'm
sorry-- the phone UI on tablets,
since the experience would not
be too jarring to the user as
they transition from one size
to another.
However, for us, it's a
completely different layout.
We recommend that the
phone UI shouldn't be used.
Instead the tablet
UI should be made
to work at its smallest size
and scaling up from there.
The main reason for these
recommendations or guidelines
is to, kind of, give the
user a consistent feel
and experience as they
resize your activity
in the same device.
So to simplify adapting your
app for multi-window mode, what
we've found is it's
better to design your app
for the smallest size first.
If you can get something
working with 220dp wide or tall,
you can-- by condensing
elements or removing
non-essential ones-- then
you can, basically, scale up
your apps you sketched from
there, adding things as needed.
A nice complementary
feature to multi-window mode
is the system-wide
drag and drop API.
With the Android drag
and drop framework,
you can allow
activities to share data
using the graphic called
drag and drop gesture.
Some of the basic
API for drag and drop
include, start drag and
drop, update drag shadow--
the drag shadow is,
really, the thumbnail
you will see when you
are actually dragging--
and cancel drag and
drop-- pretty cool API.
OK, so I said it's going
to be a short presentation.
And I would just like
to end by saying,
the Android framework-- we've
done a whole lot of working
in to add multi-window mode and
to make sure the APIs we feel
will be useful to our
developers and the UI
are supported at
the platform level.
However, that's
just half the work.
We really depend on
the app developers
to start picking up this
feature up in the N preview,
to start using it,
testing out your app,
making sure it performs
less awkwardly, and resizes.
See what kind of problems you
come up with, and providing us
feedback on things we can
improve in the platform
to make your life easier.
It's kind of a two-sided
effort to get this feature up
to a level where it
really brings joy
to the-- to all Android
users everywhere
as they use multi-window mode.
So, yeah.
So that's all I have
for the presentation.
I have some useful
links up on screen.
There are mics on
all the hallways
if you want to ask any
questions on the topic.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]